ladies and gentlemen, a
terrible tragedy took place this morning in Annecy,
small children were savagely
attacked by an individual in a park,
we are devastated by this
odious act, something that can be described
when it affects children, I think
that we are each affected at most  deep
within ourselves and today
our entire country is in shock a priori
at this stage it is a Syrian who has had
refugee status in Sweden for 10
years who asked for Asia  in France but
it was irrelevant since he already has
refugee status so he is an
individual a priori isolated if nothing with
refugee status granted in Sweden
10 years ago
I have two two-year-old children one  became
less than two three years
so that parents continue to bring
their child during play hours
because I think that trauma it will last
which will remain forever
in the city of Annecy because
it is the  first time that to my
knowledge never but now
things like this will repeat themselves in
places where no one expects it and
that's what will happen because
everyone expects it to happen
in big cities like Marseille
Paris Lyon I don't know now we are
going to steal places where no one
expects it to give for
adjustment to scare people
very young children who
are in a state of absolute emergency  and I
invite you to respect a minute of
silence for them for their family so
that we hope the consequences of
this extremely serious attack are not
consequences which would lead the nation to
be in mourning, thank you